The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CORY: I guess I'll
start now since I think
this might be the crowd since
most people are probably
sleeping after the sprint
submission deadline.
Were most people up at 6:00 AM?
Most?
Most if not all.
Alright, so, my name is Cory.
I'm from the winning
team last year
and what I really
want to do today
is kind of give a
complete information dump.
So this lecture will almost
seem like a stream of conscious,
but these are the things
that throughout all
of our years at battle code
are the things we really
wish we'd got in lecture
but never actually got.
So my goal is hopefully to give
the most relevant-- hopefully
like the most applicable
lecture to the nitty
gritty details of
the day to day.
Things that you're
doing battle code
in order to make your
bot better and try
to improve your performance
against the other teams.
So whatever competitive edge you
can glean from this hopefully
propel yourself to
the top of the ladder.
So just to give a little bit
of background about myself,
I've been in three
teams since 2010.
The first two years
where we're kind of meh.
But in 2012 we were finally
able to win the entire thing
with my teammates,
Yanping, Haitao and Justin.
And in each year was quite
different because of the people
you work with.
So what I want to do is give a
lot about our 2012 experiences,
and kind of explain the
various choices we did.
The tricks and techniques
we did in order
to give ourselves an
edge over the other team.
And I also want to give
special thanks to these four
teams in particular, Gunface,
My Archon Died Bellmanfording
the Stream, Drunkasaurus
and Toothless.
Just know that battle code
is not done in a vacuum,
and you learned from
all the other teams.
And so these teams were
particularly helpful
that our team learned from,
that our team collaborated with.
That we were able
to share code bases
and learn from each
other, et cetera.
So just to preface everything,
we're the one's, fun gamers,
is the one responsible
for the spec this year.
So if any of you guys
have problems with it,
you can't really blame Max or
Stephen, you have to blame us.
So any cries for like nerfing,
OP, whatever, it comes to us.
We made a lot of huge
changes this year
just because we wanted to
mix up the game a little bit.
And also we wanted to make it
a little bit easier for people
to start off code bases
and get running players.
I don't know how
many of you guys
played in 2010 or even
2011, but the amount
of code required to get even
a simple bot up and running
was enormous.
So in 2010, because
you couldn't actually
attack a unit until you had
equipped a gun on a robot,
it took almost one to two
days worth of code base
before you could even get a
robot moving and attacking
simultaneously.
So what we did a
lot was simplify
a huge number of things to
make it a lot more higher
level strategic control.
So no walls, attacking
is completely automatic,
we removed directionality.
I don't know how many of
you guys played last year,
but this one's pretty big.
There's no robot directionality.
We added in shared vision,
global broadcasting,
and a known map.
So do most people
enjoy these changes?
Or at least people who have
played it in previous years?
Yeah?
We're really excited,
at least, about,
in particular, having
the map completely known
and the global broadcasting,
because it allows
an unprecedented level of
robot communication this year.
So you can now,
instead of having
a bunch of almost
completely autonomous robots
with very limited
broadcasting, you
can have coordinate attacks.
You know the map.
You can design your
strategy based on the map.
Rather than wandering around
for 100 to 1000 rounds,
not knowing where to go, getting
stuck behind voids, et cetera.
The no walls is also
very interesting.
What we found in previous
years is contestants
will sometimes, if the math
is really stupid or really
retarded, what'll end
up happening is you just
watch for 3,000 rounds
both people stuck
in their base because of this
really interesting concave
of walls that prevents
the people from getting
out and actually
engaging each other.
So with no walls
you can actually
basically control
the battlefield.
You can defuse mines, you
can add your own walls,
you can prevent your
enemies from attacking.
You can create kind of--
you can bend the battlefield
to your will, which we thought
was really exciting, especially
because you're no longer
completely screwed over
if the map wasn't
what you expected.
So to begin, I want to
emphasize that battle code is
a trade off of time.
So this is what battle code
ultimately comes down to.
You have three to four
weeks to basically implement
an entire bot.
And in these three
to four weeks,
you have to decide
what is most important.
If you spend your time on the
wrong thing you will not win.
You have to spend your
time where it matters.
And, in particular, I want
to say that results to effort
vary very highly
between what you
choose to spend your time on.
So one of the most important
things to spend your time on
is attack micro.
If you can win every engagement
you will win the game.
It doesn't matter if they're
higher level strategy,
if you always win the
engagement you will beat
their army straight
up, no matter what.
OK?
Next is swarm code.
If you're swarm
moves together you'll
usually win the engagement.
If you have better swarm
code your attack micro
can be a little bit off.
But you'll still end up
engaging with larger numbers
and winning the fight.
And winning fights wins games.
The navigation code that
allows you to actually get
to the enemy swarm
and defeat them.
And then there is some
high level strategy
that you can't make
completely wrong choices.
But, once again, if you
have good attack micro,
you can make questionable
high level strategies
but still win every engagement.
So the way I'm going to
structure this lecture
is I'll have various tags.
There are certain things
that apply to novices.
There are certain things that
apply to advanced players.
And then there
are certain things
that apply to expert players.
This also comes down
to a trade off of time.
If you have four
people, maybe you
want to consider doing some
of the more advanced tricks
and tactics.
But if you only have say,
if you're working solo
or you only have
two people, you want
to spend your time
where it matters.
So don't spend time implementing
things that give you
very tiny marginal advantages
when you could, say, be
focusing on your attack micro.
And win all the battles
rather than saving maybe
like one or two bite
codes per iteration.
So first off, to do well
in battle code you really
have to know the spec.
And I know we've been really
bad at keeping the specs up
to date, there've been typos.
But hopefully by now
everything has mostly
been standardized and
corrected, and all the typos.
And then you guys didn't really
like our the diffusion/defusion
joke.
So we changed the word
defusion to diffusion
so that you guys didn't
think it was a typo
and that we were stupid.
So quick quiz, what's
the base spawn rate?
Someone call it out.
Ten.
Alright, nice.
What's the cost for
three suppliers?
Cumulative?
What was that?
I think I heard it over there.
60.
Right.
Because it starts off with
10 for the first supplier,
then the cost is the additive.
So 20 and then 30 and
to 60, 60 the total cost
for three suppliers.
What is the spawn rate
with three suppliers?
It's 8.
So total cost of three suppliers
is-- the spawn rate of three
suppliers is 8 per round
because it is kind of a curve.
The first supplier
will get you down to 9.
The second supplier will
get you down to eight.
And the third supplier is
actually the first supplier
that doesn't bring
you down another point
because it's rounded
to the nearest integer.
Even.
So in terms of unit
spawn, at out what round
does the first
supplier break even?
So these are all
like critical numbers
that if you know
you can kind of gain
the spec to your advantage.
Close.
The first supplier breaks
even at what round?
If I get one supplier,
I have one turn
spawn reduction, which
means I break even,
in terms of units,
at what round?
I sacrifice one unit
to get the supplier,
so I'll break even
when I get back
that extra unit,
which is at 90 rounds.
So the first supplier
breaks even at 90 rounds.
So these are key numbers.
They maybe tweaked
in the future,
but if you always have a
sense of all these numbers,
you can kind of make
good high level decisions
about what you
should be building
and what you
shouldn't be building
at the beginning of the game.
So the beginning of
the game is very key.
What we did was you have
an excess of energy.
So you have a choice, like
in Max's lecture yesterday,
whether to build
generators or suppliers.
And if you know roughly at what
time these things break even,
or at what time you gain
that the marginal advantage,
you can decide when to
attack or when not to attack.
So know the specs,
that's very key.
Second, I want to say
testing is probably
the most important thing,
second from spending
your time in the correct place.
Because you don't
actually know if you're
spending your time
in the correct place
unless you're actually
testing the code.
So as a high level, you want to
write multiple distinct bots.
So I know a lot of teams maybe
just have a single bot lineage.
But our team we wrote like 10
to 12 different bots, each one
with different strategies.
And sometimes we wrote bots
completely from scratch
when we thought we had
a really cool strategy.
So last year there
were flying units.
So we thought, well it
would be kind of cool maybe
if we could have
units that only--
or if we had a base that
only spawned flying units.
And we did a little bit of
theory crafting our head
and it turned out the DPS
was marginally higher.
But the problem is once
we tried to implement it,
we found out the actual
problems with the flyer strategy
was that we couldn't sustain
the units because of the way
that energy transfer
was done last year.
And we weren't actually able
to coordinate the attack well
enough to gain that
theoretical DPS.
So testing is
extremely important.
Wins, of course,
beat theory crafting.
So even knowing the specs and
knowing the break off times,
you have to be able to
implement them in practice,
otherwise the theory
doesn't pay off.
The scrimmage server is
your ally in testing.
And then you always want to
prioritize writing behaviors
over spending a lot of
time doing framework code.
Because the behaviors
are what you're
actually testing,
not the framework.
One thing that novices make
the mistake of is they're
always afraid of ranked games.
So has everyone in here played
at least one ranked game?
Yes?
So what I want to
say is it's really
a problem more with novices
than with the people who
have been doing battle
code for a long time.
And the reason this is,
is because sometimes you
submit a bot and you're afraid
that it's maybe not so good.
Or there's some
problems with it.
Or that your code
is going to do badly
and you're going to lose points.
But what it gains you
is by scrimmaging often
you will always know what
the top teams are up to.
And the thing is,
if you do unranked,
top teams actually have no
incentive to accept your match,
and you'll never know what
they're actually doing.
So the trade off is a top
team, if they beat you
in a ranked game,
they'll actually
gain [? ELOW ?] points.
But you actually gain
something from that.
You gain the understanding of
how the top team is micro-ing.
The kind of high level
strategy the top team is doing.
And also any tips or
tricks or small things
that you can glean
from those games
to perform better in
your next bot iteration.
Actually if you send an unranked
game to one of the top teams,
it's actually a lose-lose
situation for them.
Because A they have
the probability
of losing a lot
of points to you.
And B they're also giving away
their high level strategy.
So for the top five teams,
at least in years past,
if you sent them
an unranked match,
they'd cancel it and send
you back a ranked match.
Because there's almost
no advantage for them
to accept these
unranked matches.
So don't be afraid of
sending ranked games,
especially against top
teams, because that's
where you're going to
learn the most about how
you can improve your bot.
Another thing that sometimes
beginners get wrong
is that your code base is
actually more than your bot.
There is a huge
infrastructure that we
built, at least around
our bot last year,
that was not just the simple--
that was not just robot player
and everything
surrounding robot player.
So one of the easiest
things you can do
is you can make custom maps.
Every year when we start
battle code, we always
make this map on the
right, we call it plains,
because there's
absolutely nothing on it.
The plains for this year,
we have a few encampments
in the middle just to test like
basic encampment capture code.
But what plains
really allows you
to do is it allows you to
perfect your attack micro
and make it so that you're not
worrying about like advance
path finding, you're just making
sure you can win engagements.
Because, as I said, attack
micro is so important.
Winning engagements wins games.
So spend time, actually,
making custom maps.
I know we don't really have
a map editor out this year.
So if you make a
map editor, too,
make a bunch of custom maps.
Test your path finding,
test your attack micro.
There's so many
small things you can
do to test your bot very fast.
A few small things that you
guys may have also not known
is with custom maps
you can actually
declare units to be
pre-spawned on the map.
So in the top right you're
allowed to declare symbols.
You can actually set
up unit formations
to quickly test
different scenarios.
And just by hitting play
and repeatedly running it,
you can tweak
whatever heuristics
you're running in order to make
sure that your code is actually
running correctly.
And then making
custom maps is also
extremely good for
testing path finding.
So you can spawn a map with
a unit already in the center,
and then just hard code
in an endpoint to Nav2.
And then see if
your navigation is
running any better
than it was before.
This is kind of a
little expert thing
but we spent a lot
last year trying
to gain the scrimmage
server a little bit.
So Justin wrote kind
of a scraper that
scrapes the rankings
every five minutes
and determines who's
winning to who.
If you guys are
just starting out
don't worry about this too much.
But what this allowed
us to do, actually,
was it allowed us to know
which teams were actually
rising quickly, which teams had
maybe changed their strategy.
And it allowed us to kind of
target our ranked matches.
Because we would
see oh this team
won three games in
rapid succession,
we want to see
what they're doing.
Or oh this team maybe
dropped four games
and we probably
don't really need
to send them a ranked match
because they're probably
not doing anything
different than what
they used to be doing.
But, once again,
this is a custom tool
that was written outside
of the framework of just
our eclipse project with
our battle code bot that
allowed us to gain a small
competitive edge over everyone
else.
The current ladder stats
ranking system is actually--
I think Justin posted
about in the forums,
he's actually running
it publicly for you
guys this year.
So if you want to take a
peek and just use his code--
Our old one actually recorded
[? ELOW ?] gains and losses.
So we could see whether
a team gained 1 point
or whether they gained 10.
So if a team gained 30
points in a single match,
that's like a warning
bell, alright?
Because it means they're doing
something drastically different
and you want to know
what they're up to.
This tool was another tool
we borrowed from Gunface
from 2011.
It's basically a
mass scrim tester.
So the scrimmage server
actually is not the only place
that you can mass scrim.
You can also build
your own custom mass
scrimming framework, which
is what Gunface did in 2011
and what we co-opted
from them in 2012.
So what this actually
allows us to do
is it allows us to test
in house our own bots
against each other.
So you know how I said we wrote
like 10 to 12 distinct bots?
Well what we would do
is we could actually
characterize which
one was strictly
superior to all the other
bots by pitting them
against each other in
thousands of matches.
So if you'll see
here, what this did
was we had a total win counter.
So we could submit jobs
to our queue server.
The queue would run like 50-60
matches on every single known
map in the scrimmage ranking.
And then, of course, it
takes some time to compute.
We actually borrowed a
bunch of xVM machines
to continuously run
this in the background.
But you'll see here every single
one of our tagged releases,
we're actually pitting
it against each other.
Last year we would
consider a bot good
if we could beat our older
iterations 90% of the time.
And until we could get
kind of that 90% mark
we would consider them
about to be equal.
Because some small change, in
maybe like the random number
generator, whatever,
would affect
the outcome of the match.
But, again, the most
drastic improvements--
when you see 31-0,
those are from usually
from micro improvements
where one bot will just--
the two armies will collide and
one bot will just obliterate
the other one, even
with equal numbers.
But these sort of things,
running the mass scrim,
you can really,
really get a sense of.
This is an expert
level kind of thing.
If you don't have--
if you have one person
you're not going
to blow your time
writing a scrimmage
based system.
But if you have maybe
three or four people
you could take a
day or so to maybe
try to repurpose the old
2012 mass scrim tester, which
is on GitHub, by the way, to get
it working with the 2013 game.
One thing that hasn't really
been covered ever, I think,
is kind of the byte
code system in detail,
I think in battle code.
And this is a very key
part of battle code
and yet it's always
kind of glossed over.
You'll hear the lecturer say
you should use less byte codes.
Or the less byte codes you use
the more units you can have.
But what does that
actually mean and how
does that actually translate
into implementation?
So I'll skip ahead and just
give a brief overview of the JVM
for people who are
unfamiliar with it.
So the Java Virtual Machine
is a stack based system.
So what it basically means is
if you're familiar with x86
or whatever, there
are no registers
is just a giant stack.
And you can imagine it as
values get pushed on the stack
and popped off of the stack, and
that's how computation is done.
Byte codes are-- when
you write your Java
it gets compiled into
something called byte codes.
And byte codes are very
similar to assembly,
except they work on this
stacked based system.
And the way this
stack is, is you
have this operand stack which
is your current stack of values.
So if you imagine like
a prefix operations
I can push-- or
postfix operations,
I can push to values on
the stack, I can call add
and it would pop off
the result, right?
So if you imagine the JVM is
kind of working like that,
it's very similar.
But there's also an array
of local variables up top
and these are
indexed by a number.
So, actually, stack operands
can operate directly
onto the array of variables
that are globally accessible.
And then there's also
a global constants pool
that byte codes can operate on.
So this is just
an example online.
And if you want to read more
there's a URL down here.
But what happens is
you compile your Java,
it gets turned into byte codes,
and each byte code is actually
stepped through by our
instrumentation engine.
And that's what you're
getting counted on.
So when someone says
you're using 10 byte codes,
it actually means that
the high level Java
call you made is
being turned into 10
individual atomic
steps on the JVM.
And you're getting penalized for
each one of these atomic steps.
This leads to a lot
of interesting things.
So there's a very classic
kind of loop structure
in battle code.
I hear this is so
classic, actually,
that Dropbox's code base is
littered with this structure.
So it looks like kind
of a normal for loop,
but if you look closely, you'll
notice that we don't even
have a third parameter.
What this says is that for
i is equal to the length
of the ray, decrement until
you're greater than zero.
And it's reversed from maybe
the way normal computer
science would teach it to you.
But there's a particular
reason we do it this way.
And that's because we're
actually byte code hacking.
So what happens is Java is
similar-- kind of like there's
legacy in computers
testing again zero
is actually an operation
that comes up very often.
In most branch conditions
you're testing against zero.
Like Booleans are testing
against zero, et cetera.
So there's actually
a special byte code
for testing against zero.
And then, also, when
you're doing the comparison
you don't want to
be recomputing,
say, msgs.length
every single time.
So this actually
has a net effect
of saving byte codes
because you can actually
write the byte codes
out but you can
predict what the
compiler will spit out.
And because battle
code is not run as just
in time compilation,
actually, the byte code
steps through exactly
as its outputted.
This ends up with a net
savings of a few byte codes.
So if you'll see down here,
this is like the classic way
you would write a
loop that you might
learn in intro to
computer science.
For i is equal to
zero, i is less
than your terminating
condition, increment i.
What happens here
is because you want
to compare i every
round to msgs.length.
Computing msgs.length
is actually
a separate compare operation
with loading the actual object,
loading the actual array object.
Whereas in our initial
version what we've done here
is we've set the index variable
actually to the final value.
And we're comparing
against zero,
which is a single
byte code operation.
So what happens is that
this is a net savings
of two byte codes.
Two byte codes actually
might not seem like a lot,
but if you're, say,
looping through 100 objects
that that's 200 byte codes
saved in the entire loop.
And that's two whole
sense functions.
So you could send-- that's two
whole global sense functions,
with the radius
and the location.
That's actually pretty big.
So saving 200 byte
codes can mean
that you might have additional
data on the battlefield.
Or you can loop through one
additional object when you're
trying to compute a
heuristic for map locations
or for army positions.
And this actually gives you a
small marginal competitive edge
over the other team.
Especially this year
when byte codes also
translates to energy.
So saving byte codes gives
you back more energy.
More energy translates
to more units.
If all your units are saving
500 byte codes per turn
that adds up over time,
especially with the decay rate.
So with byte codes
you'll also end up
wanting to implement
your own data structures.
So I don't know if you guys
have tried using the native Java
data structures like hashset,
array q set, et cetera.
But we actually penalize
you for the internal calls
that Java makes in
those data sets.
So if Java-- Java
likes to be very safe.
So a lot of the
thread safe code we'll
check to make sure
another thread is not
trying to mutate the
data, or that there's
on a lock on the
data, et cetera.
So the thread safe
code actually ends up
hurting you a lot,
because there's
a lot of excess byte
codes that gets called.
So, for instance, a single
hashset.iterator.getnext
getting a value from
a hashset, worst case
is 2k byte codes for a
single call, which is absurd.
Because you can implement a
hashset yourself with an array
and maybe like 200-300 byte
codes if you custom write it.
So what ends up happening
is a lot of people
will make what's
called fast data sets.
So we wrote a fast
hashset, a fast arraylist.
And these are all
custom based on arrays
that we could index
directly into and pay
a very minimal byte
code cost in order
to get very complex
data structures back.
Same thing goes for algorithms.
You may think that--
a lot of beginners
will start off trying
to implement something
like [? astar ?] or a flood
fill algorithm just to do
navigation.
Yes?
Right, this is an example from--
I'll explain what
exactly this one is.
But just an overview,
most n squared
algorithms are completely
untenable in the byte code
system.
So if you see an n
squared algorithm
it's not going to work unless
you do something to it.
So there are multiple ways.
You can distribute it
among multiple robots,
which is actually very hard.
You can break up the
computation into multiple steps
and run a piece each
turn, which is hard
depending on the algorithm.
And then you can also just run a
completely different algorithm.
So the one I actually
have up here,
this is a cute little example
from our old code base.
It's not the actual
implementation
but it's the algorithm itself.
This is called a
multiply with carry.
It's actually a pseudo
random number generator.
There's a period-- there's
like a period of 2 to the 60th.
But for all intents
and purposes it
is a random number generator.
We actually implemented
this because we
noticed that math.random on
seeding pays 144 byte codes.
And then each subsequent
getnextinteger call is 80.
And we actually wrote our own
custom random number generator
to save 40 byte codes
per call to get nextint.
And so this is the algorithm
actually pulled from Wikipedia,
we changed a little bit.
But, in essence, it's a
bunch of bit operators
that gives you a
pseudo random number
generator to save on byte codes.
And if you have
an algorithm that
relies on a lot
of random numbers
the 40 per getnextinteger
actually adds up.
There's actually a tool,
a really nice tool,
that we used a lot last year
call doctor garbage visualizer.
I don't know why it's called
doctor garbage, because it's
one of the best tools ever.
But what it does is it
actually decompiles your class
into the actual byte codes.
And then it shows the control
flow graph on the right.
So the control flow graph will
actually allow you to reason
about where your short
circuits are happening,
because if you short
circuit a code block,
you're not actually paying
the byte code for what
you don't execute, right?
So you'll want to
terminate loops
end-- you'll want to
terminate loops early.
You'll want to try
to avoid code that
doesn't have to be
computed multiple times
in order to reduce your
total byte code count.
So by having the control
flow graph on the right,
it's actually very
easy to reason
about how to save byte
codes, especially when
you'll see the control flow
graph, plus the instruction,
plus kind of a small comment
about what the variable is
or what the method call is
or what the constant is.
So that's enough for-- So,
ultimately, with byte codes,
the last thing I'll say is
if you're not sure, test it.
We give you a function
called getbytecodesnum
and this allows you
to see what byte
code number you're
currently executing.
So if I want to profile
a particular function
call or a particular
algorithm, just
surround it with two system.out
print line getbytecodenum.
And this will tell you the
total number of byte codes
that your algorithm
took to execute.
And you can use this to
kind of profile it down.
You can try different
things but ultimately
whatever gets that
number smallest
is what helps you bot when
you're optimizing algorithms.
We actually, at the bottom,
this is a little loop
that-- or this is
a little function
call that I've added
at least every year.
At the end of
every robot's round
it actually checks
the round number
and the current byte
code number to see
if it went over byte codes.
And it will actually emit a
warning to the system console
that it went over byte codes.
So actually it's really
annoying but it's really helpful
that if every time a
robot goes over byte codes
it yells at you.
Because then you can play
match if you're not actually
profiling something-- or
if you're not actually
explicitly saying
that, you can sometimes
ignore it because the
byte code number is just
in the top right of the client
and you'll kind of miss it
sometimes.
You'll see like, oh, maybe
it's like 10k or whatever.
But if your robot is yelling at
you every time it goes over 10k
and your entire
army just screens
in the middle of battle,
there's something
that has to be changed in order
to make it so that you're not
missing an attack--
or you're not
missing a movement every turn
that you could be moving.
So this year, actually,
it's even more critical
because there are no cool downs.
Every robot, every
turn, can move.
So if you go over
byte codes once,
that's a lost
movement, which could
translate to a lost attack.
So it's very critical
in battle situations
that you do not
go over byte code
so you can get your movement.
And I'll show you why in a bit
especially in micro situations.
So micro is really
important, attack micro,
I've been emphasizing
this over and over.
You should know the execution
order of the robots.
But you should know
what happens when.
So when do attacks happen.
So when do attacks happen?
At the end of the round, right.
You should understand the
discrete nature of the map
and you should know that micro's
better than everything else.
So I don't know if
Max has covered this,
but in two robots which robot
actually wins the one v one
engagement?
It is-- yes, it's the one
who closes the gap first,
is the one who wins
the engagement.
So if I have two robots,
two squares apart, right now
it's a stalemate.
But if red makes the mistake to
move in, what happens is blue
closes the distance and
gets the attack off first.
And, all things being equal,
red will attack second.
But blue has already done
the initial damage, which
means on blue's turn
where he kills red,
red will not deal back
the corresponding damage
to kill blue.
Blue will win.
So blue will have one more
robot in the next upcoming
engagement and
therefore higher DPS
and will win the next battle.
This situation is
also particularly bad
because red can't
actually retreat.
If red moves back, blue can
still close the gap next turn.
So understanding how the
micro works in this game
is actually very key
to winning engagements.
So in a one v one
situation the gap closer
always has the advantage.
Just a straight up.
So you will want to write code
that takes this into account,
so that you can actually
win engagements.
In a two v two situation, it's
a little bit more complex.
So what happens in two v two?
So red can move forward.
Blue can close the gap,
but red can close the gap
with the second unit.
And now he's dealing
twice DPS that blue
has and will eventually win.
Blue can actually--
if blue is clever,
blue can actually micro to
focus fire on a single unit,
because damage is split evenly
across all enemy robots.
So blue can actually
try to micro little bit
to kill the bottom red unit,
if red makes a mistake.
But red will actually-- can
move down and continuously
attack blue until the
blue robot is dead.
And the two v one will win.
And if red micros correctly
he won't lose a single unit.
So in a large flight--
in larger fights,
the larger army
has the advantage
given correct positioning.
Because you could assume in
this sort of scenario blue
can actually reduce this
to a one v one flight
if red does not make the correct
choices in the subsequent five
or six moves.
So blue ball will move up
and attack red and reduce it
to a one v one scenario
unless the red robot can
retreat backwards while
still attacking blue
towards the bottom red unit and
continue fighting so that they
can turn the one v one into
a two v one engagement.
But these small, discrete steps
are what you should actually
be thinking about when
you're writing microcode.
It's very critical that you
don't get indefinitely kited.
It's very critical you do
not write code that ends up
in this scenario
where you're attacking
and you try to retreat,
but you can't actually
retreat in this game,
because the opponent will
close the distance.
So there's only two scenarios
in which you can retreat.
You can retreat if
there's an army behind you
willing to back you up.
Or you can treat if you're
retreating over a mine.
That gives you more DPS.
So there's some
team dynamics things
that I just want to cover.
This is mostly geared towards
the novices in the room.
But make sure you guys are
using source control management.
I think this goes
without saying,
every MIT class now
emphasizes the importance
of source control management.
And I'll even say you should
just use hosted source control
management.
So if you're using Git,
if you're using Mercurial,
you should just throw it up on
one of these free hosted SCMs
just because you
don't want to deal
with the server going down.
So my first year we made
the terrible mistake
of hosting our own SVN
server on an xVM machine
from [INAUDIBLE].
And then randomly there was some
down time that was uncontrolled
and we didn't have access to
our code base for like two days.
So it was terrible.
So just-- GitHub, these guys
are paid to keep your source up,
OK?
So [INAUDIBLE] is not paid to
maintain that your battle code
source does not go down.
So trust these large
source control guys.
And especially trust
distributed source control,
if you guys are familiar.
I think Max gave a lecture on
Git, so use it effectively.
And also figure out your SCM--
your source control strategy.
So this is actually a big one.
Every team does they're kind of
release cycle or, I would say,
release cycle but you're like
releasing bots, a little bit
differently.
So I'll explain
the way we did it.
We had a single
package called Ducks,
just because we
really like ducks.
Don't ask.
We forked off a bot
every time we release it.
So in our mainline
Ducks package,
when we get to a state, we're
saying this bot's reasonable.
We want to submit
it to the server.
We'll actually copy
the Ducks package,
rename it to our kind of
bot naming scheme, which
is based on SC2AI levels,
if you guys play Starcraft.
And so we started off
with a medium player.
So we'll copy the Duck's package
into the medium player package.
And what this allows
you to do is always
have a copy of the medium
player in your repository.
So you can always
pit your mainline bot
against any of the
other heads you've
cut off from the repository.
So some teams like
to do it differently.
I know Gunface in 2011 liked
to use source control tagging.
So what this allowed
them to do was
they could update to any
version in the source control.
And they could recompile it.
But the issue with
that is if you
update you have to update
your entire mainline package
backwards.
You have to
recompile it, and you
have to keep the class files
around so that you can pit them
against your
current bot once you
re-update to the current head.
This gets a little bit annoying.
And for us it was just
simpler to persist
like 30-40 copies of
the same file just
in different packages.
Because it saves on time.
It's not elegant, but
elegance doesn't really
matter that much
when you're trying
to finish a bot in the short
amount of time that you have.
We actually went
one step further.
This is technically part
of the custom tools,
but we actually had One
touch deploy system.
So we had a single
script that was
responsible for building the
release, tagging the release,
testing the release on our
automated mass testing system.
And then cutting the
branch from mainline
and pushing it back
to the repository.
This is very key,
actually, if you're
doing what some of you
guys may have been doing
last night in trying to
submit like 20 seconds
before the deadline.
Because if something goes wrong
you're completely screwed.
So if you have a tool
that you know works
and you know roughly the
amount of time it takes
for it to work,
it's standardized
and you're less
prone to human error.
So we ran the script.
Everything's done.
We have a jar.
We upload the jar.
We're done.
And this is reliable
that we're not manually
trying to create the zip file.
I know some people
have been having
issues with bots
randomly exploding.
Or sometimes a submission
works or sometimes a submission
doesn't work.
If the whole thing
is automated it's
going to work barring
some catastrophic failure.
This is also a random
cute little tip.
Sorry for this
stream of conscious,
but I'm just trying to mind
up as much useful information
on to you.
This one I'm actually
really surprised,
I couldn't figure this
out for like three years.
How to deal with
shared debugging.
So for those of you
guys working in teams,
you'll have print lines,
you'll have indicator strings
that one day you'll
be testing something
and you'll merge in
someone else's pull.
And then you'll be like who
overwrote my indicator strings?
Because now I don't
know what I'm debugging.
Have any of you
guys had this issue?
So you'll have--
you're debugging nav
and you're printing
out the current Nav
state-- your current state
machine's navigation position,
and all the sudden the guy
working on attack micro
has overwrote your indicator
strings with current number
of robots attacking
you, or whatever.
And this gets really
frustrating really fast.
Because then you end up
with merge conflicts,
when people try change each
others indicator strings.
The guy working on nav will con
out the attack guy's indicator
strings.
And then you'll end up
with a merge conflict
and then you guys will
screw up the merge conflict.
And stuff will just go to hell.
So what we did was
the bots can actually
read from the Java bc.config.
And actually what we built was
this custom system, this custom
debug system, that
allowed us to specify
who was running the bot based
on the current eclipse launch
profile, and only print
out indicator strings
from the person watching it.
So you'll see on the left
we made four custom launch
profiles.
One for me, one for Justin,
one for Haitao, one for YP.
And when you ran your
custom launch profile,
it would only display debug
information from your bot.
So you'd only see
your own print lines.
You'd only see your
own indicator strings.
And then we never
had a merge conflict.
Well, we did have
merge conflicts
but not related to
indicator string setting.
So this is just a
small little trick
that just saves a lot of time.
Because stuff will add up
across your total bot's
development time.
You don't want to spend
time arguing about people--
I know some teams
will say, OK, you
can only use
indicator string one.
I'll only use
indicator string two.
But someone will need
two lines of information.
Then you guys will fight over
it and it's really stupid.
Other general, useful advice.
All the past teams have actually
put a lot of information on.
So there's a lot of stuff that
I don't need to reiterate.
So how many of you guys
actually read the blog post
that I put on hacker news?
Yeah, nice.
From 2012 to 2009, actually,
all the old strategy reports,
all the winning teams,
are actually online.
So I have the bug
post from our team,
but there's also
a strategy report
that corresponds to that, to our
bot, that's in our repository.
The 2011 post-mortem is
actually an excellent
write up by Steve Arcangeli,
who wrote the massive scrim
tester about
various other tricks
you can do to save byte codes.
2010 is by Spencer Skates
on finding the shortest
path to victory.
It's kind of their whole like
Bellman Ford pun team thing
that they had going on.
They detail a lot of
high level mechanics
that help you when
you're in combat.
They also-- Spencer Skates
and Steve Bartell also won
in '09 and they were called
G2G Ice Skating Lessons,
which was-- it was like an
inside joke that none of us
got.
But they wrote about their
2009 experiences as well.
They actually set the trend of
the winning team usually ending
up writing the best
strategy reports, which
is a trend you guys
should continue.
Some other random tips.
Messaging.
I'm really excited about
the new changes this year,
because messaging is global.
So what this allows you
to do is you no longer
have to have robots
really close together.
So if you guys are familiar
with the 2011 game, what
you would have to do is, because
you could only broadcast eight
squares away, you had to set up
a relay network of robots that
would propagate
information outwards.
And it was a whole amount
of overhead just associated
with writing the
relay network that
could get a message from
robot a to your entire army.
That was at least a
day's worth of work.
Setting up the re-broadcasting.
Setting up the hashing.
Setting up all that code.
This year, because everything
is a global message board,
it makes it easier to broadcast
very important information very
fast to all your robots.
But what this also
does is battle code
has a huge history of
message based attacks.
So it also makes
the message based
attacks more interesting because
now the enemy very easily can
see everything you're
writing to the board.
So some of the more
famous message attacks
have been one year-- you guys
are familiar that the robot VM
limit is eight megs, right?
So if you exceed
eight megs, your robot
actually automatically uploads.
So one year, a team went around
just broadcasting eight megs
arrays.
So the enemy team would
either get it, try to process,
and completely freeze.
They'd get it,
try to process it,
and explode immediately,
because they
loaded into memory or
something stupid like that.
Or they would just stop
moving because they constantly
exceed their byte code limit.
Then, I think in like '07,
teams were trying to exploit
the fixed cost of
array.hashcode.
So array.hashcode used
to be a single byte code.
We used to-- there is a package
in your distributable battle
code installer
called method costs,
and that explains the cost of
every single method that we
don't explicitly
list a cost for--
Or if a method is
not listed in there
it's free unless it's in one
of the restricted packages.
But what happened was
array.hashcodes was free.
So teams thought they
were being really clever
by using the o of
one hashcode cost
to basically do an
o of n algorithm
to get entire hashcode and
secure their messages that way.
But then one team
just took the fact
that every team was
using array.hashcode
and he could mutate the
array without changing
the value of the final hash.
And then he would send
that back to the robot
and all their robots would
just completely mess up.
Because they thought
the hash was correct,
but the data was
completely garbled,
which which was a really
interesting messaging attack.
So you need to make sure
when your messaging to check
the integrity of the data and
make sure that the data-- check
the validity of
the data and also
make sure that the
data actually gets
to where it's supposed to go.
So, this year the most
obvious attack, of course,
is to wipe the entire board.
And you can do this every round
if you have some obscene number
of generators, like 30 or so.
But the thing is, you can
pool energy this year.
So actually a team
that, say, just wants
to wipe the message board
during critical situations,
like during an engagement, can
actually pool enough energy
so that they can wipe the
entire message board in one go.
So you can't actually
assume that what
you wrote into the message
board one round will actually
be their the next round,
or even between rounds.
Because a robot-- The enemy
robot who executed between you
could have wiped it.
So make sure that whatever
messaging scheme you use,
there's a way to check
the validity either
by hashing and storing maybe
the top four bytes as your hash.
Or by duplicating the
information in multiple places
and checking that all
the information matches
with each other.
But as long as you can reliably
get important information over.
Like if you had a retreat
signal, or an all out attack
signal, just make
sure it's secured
and it's safely propagated
to all your robots.
Here's a random piece of advice.
Keep your frameworks
lean, especially
with the byte code limit.
You don't want to create
this beautiful hierarchy
of abstract interfaces
that just has
a ton of intermediate
layers before you actually
get to the nitty gritty code.
Because for every additional
layer of abstraction,
you're increasing
the byte code cost.
So actually one of the cool
things that the byte code
limitation actually enforces is
it enforces really lean code,
which is not something
you typically see in Java.
So if you'll actually look
at our class structure,
this is from our 2012 bot, we
have a very, very flat class
hierarchy.
One, because we just didn't want
to deal with extra subpackages.
And two, because
there's really not
too much to be gained from
really elegant architecture
other than just wasting time.
Because the behavior code
is ultimately what matters.
So we wrote extremely
lean frameworks.
So this is actually
our main run loop.
You'll see here all we do is
we reset our internal timers.
We update a few key
round variables,
like the current time,
and my current energy,
and the current position
of all the bases.
And then we run
our message system.
We actually run the main run
call, which would basically
be a giant state
machine, probably like
500, 600 to 1,000
lines long of just
completely messy code that
determines what the robot wants
to do and does it.
And then we actually
abstracted movement out.
This was probably the
biggest piece of abstraction
that we did, was we
moved a movement out
to a separate position where
we knew that each robot was
reliably moving
every single round,
because it's very key that
you always move because that
is an impact on your
total damage per second.
And then we did
some generic things.
And we also have this cute
little thing down here
at the bottom which is if we had
some spare byte codes we would
use the extra byte
codes for computation.
So navigation last year
was-- because there
were walls, the
algorithms you had
to use last year were
actually quite different.
Most teams would write
something called bugnav,
which-- you guys from
the navigation lecture,
I suppose you discussed a little
bit, where you see an obstacle,
you hit the obstacle, you try
to trace around the obstacle,
and then once you're free of
the obstacle you keep moving.
But the more advanced
teams would actually
write a more complex
version of bugnav which
is called tangentbug, which
is-- you basically can project
a virtual bug and if you
see you've rounded a corner,
instead of going forward,
hitting the wall,
and going around it, you
can just cut the corner.
And we actually used
our extra byte codes
to pre-compute steps
of tangentbug in order
to make our navigation maybe
five or six squares better.
But that better means you get
to the enemy two rounds faster
because you cut a corner.
And then two rounds faster means
you have extra DPS on the enemy
and so you win that
initial engagement.
This year because there
are no permanent walls,
bugnav and tangentbug
may not actually
be some of the best algorithms.
Haitao and I have kind
of a little bet running
on what the best nav will be.
We're thinking
it's probably going
to be some sort of very
discretized floodfill algorithm
or Astar algorithm that doesn't
try to compute every square
but actually breaks everything
up into discrete segments.
So you want to be able
to rush to the enemy base
if they're just a
straight up nuke bot.
We guarantee you a
round-- we guarantee you
a minimum of 200 rounds if
you follow the optimal path.
But you have to know
what that optimal path is
or you won't get there in time.
Maximum of 200 rounds.
So our bets are actually
on the most advanced teams
writing kind of
an Astar algorithm
or a floodfill algorithm
that takes the map,
divides it into discrete
chunks so it doesn't consider
every individual square,
and then it kind of picks
sort of roughly the
best path to take.
So you can avoid areas
with more or less mines
than the other areas.
And then this will still get you
to the nuke bot in enough time
without having to
blow the entire cost
of the complete Astar algorithm.
So Astar, in maybe like an
eight by eight or ten by ten
is tenable, but it's
not tenable in twenty
by twenty or a hundred
by a hundred situations.
This is kind of a big one.
Don't be afraid to
write messy code.
I think it speaks for
itself, but in case
you guys are like spending
a lot of time trying
to make beautiful
code, the thing
is what you ship is
ultimately-- what
you ship that changes your
bot's performance is ultimately
what matters.
And a lot of beginners
have this issue
where they're afraid
to just hack something
together, or hack a
one off bot to test.
But it's so key that you
kind of overcome this fear
to write messy code,
write stuff that works,
just get something hacked
out that's working.
And then use that
to gain yourself
an advantage in
what matters, which
is the actual scrimmage, the
tournament matches, et cetera.
So we actually have
code that's terrible.
Our navigation code
actually is completely--
is not understandable by the
person who wrote it anymore
because it's so messy.
Like you can imagine,
bugnav, for anyone
who's tried to implement
bugnav it sounds really simple,
but there are actually like
100s or so of edge cases
that you have to account for.
So if you end up bugging around
another robot or you end up
in some sort of
infinite loop bug,
there's a lot of extra edge
conditions that you have
to account for that none of
the previous lecturers have
actually talked about
from '09 or 2010 or 2011.
They'll just say oh
yeah, it's bugnav,
just go around the thing.
But what happens if you
have two units bugging
around the same wall and
then they hit each other,
then one unit has to go around.
But if one unit goes around
and the unit on top moves,
all of the sudden
you have a unit
who's no longer next
to a wall but though he
was bugging around a wall.
But he doesn't see any
walls next to him anymore.
And then you're
states get messed up.
And everything
just goes to hell.
So don't be afraid to
just write edge case
code that deals with
that, gets your bot up
and running so you can test the
frameworks, and the strategies,
and everything that matters.
There's also-- last minute
hacks actually win games.
So I don't know if you guys
are familiar with our 2011--
or 2012 championship.
But what we did was
on the very last day
we were scrimmaging
on the server
and we found out that the second
place scrim team, team 16,
had modified his attack
code, that it was actually
slightly better than ours.
And because having
better attack code
means you win the engagement, it
means he beat our bot actually
three times out of four.
So we got, actually,
really scared about this.
And don't forget
we scrimmed this
the day of the
final submissions.
So an hour before the
deadline, me, Haitao, and YP
are just thinking about well
what should we actually do?
So our ultimate hack was
we actually figure out
what the team is by the
characteristic of their message
broadcasting.
So you're not actually
given the team number.
But if you look at what kind
of messages they're sending,
you can kind of guess, right?
And throughout the
whole battle code 2012
we had been kind of on
the side just curious,
looking at the structure
of other teams messages.
And so an hour before
the deadline submission
we wrote something
that determined
whether the team we were
playing against was team 16.
And we would change
our strategy.
And this was an hour before.
And it was completely
untested code.
But we had been thinking
about it, kind of
in the back of our mind, and
we just threw this together.
We uploaded it.
And if you were at the finals
it was a pretty tense match
where we actually had
a bug in that code that
triggered once and would
not trigger a second time.
But the one time it did trigger
was the very last match,
and so we ultimately won
the final tournament.
But this is like a piece of
code, incredibly critical.
It's like three or
four lines, but it
was the difference between
first or second place.
So once again, spending time
where it matters is really key.
You can probably do these
sort of hacks this year.
Determining what the team is
based on the message structure
is a little bit harder.
Because last year people would
send discrete message objects.
And so you could
count the total number
of integers, the total
number of map locations.
Whether there's a
secret key and then
you could correlate
the secret keys.
This year you'll have to
see how they channel hop
or what they store on
the various channels,
or the channel distribution
of the different messages.
But it's still possible.
So last minute
hacks do win games.
This is also another small one.
You guys should all-- if
you're not already using IRC,
you should use IRC, because
all the devs are on IRC,
especially us who are remote.
I was the only person working
on engine who was actually
willing to fly out six
hours to give this talk.
So everyone else is on IRC.
If you have any questions
you should go on IRC
and you should actually
ask your question.
So, for those of you who don't
know, there's a web client.
Just use the
freenode web client,
connect to channel
battle code, ask
whatever questions you have.
We'll answer them pretty fast.
If you guys are feeling
a little more advanced,
you should use IRC better.
If you actually
parsesys in the channel
there's a lot of banter that
goes on regarding game balance.
Or teams will discuss
strategies or whatever.
So if you actually
get a good IRC client
and stay in the channel,
you'll actually learn a lot.
Because sometimes some of
the old battle code champions
will just come in, just talk
a little bit about strategy.
Or people will just
discuss what they've
been doing on the
bots, et cetera.
And so just use a
good IRC chat client.
If you were to
use pigeon, pigeon
has a built-in IRC client.
There's no reason to
not connect to it.
Talk to the devs, ask questions.
There's just been a lot
of very simple questions,
but we're more than
happy to answer.
So questions about
round number, or if you
have an issue with
your bot, it's
much faster than the
forums, because we'll
answer the IRC
probably in minutes
rather than hours on the forum.
And, most of all, you
guys should just have fun.
Battle code, at least for us,
was a very fun experience.
We worked hard on it.
But we also-- we
goofed off a lot.
We probably spent more than
40 hours playing Civ 5.
And before the
sprint tournament,
or before the Qualls tournament,
this is usually a bad idea.
But it's about-- this is
IP, it's about having fun.
So work hard, but also have fun.
And also I have a few requests.
So there may potentially be
the 2013 winner in this group.
So, if it is one of you
guys, just a few requests.
You guys should write
a good strategy report,
because battle code is
not done in a vacuum.
We learned from the
teams before us.
The teams before us learned
from the teams before them.
This information really needs
to be more out and open,
which is why I'm giving
you kind of a brain
dump of a lot of the
very small tricks
and tips that we did in order
to gain a competitive edge.
So write a good strategy report,
help your fellow competitors.
This is a friendly competition,
it's not cutthroat.
You guys can make fun of all
the other lesser competitions,
but within battle code
keep it a good family.
And then join the
devs if you guys win,
because we need good desks.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
CORY: So any general
questions or whatever?
Once again, yeah, it's our
fault if you guys really
hate nuke you should say it now.
Yes?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It changes
from year to year.
So how did you choose your team?
CORY: The 2012 team was
all Star League people.
So there's also another
Star League team.
I have some high hopes
for the Star League guys.
First year I did it with
people from my high school.
Second year I did it, I did
it with Star League people.
The third year was also all
Star League people as well.
You guys should go to Star
League if you like Starcraft.
That's a pitch.
Every Friday at 7:00
o'clock for 253.
Go play Starcraft
It'll make your meta
game analysis better.
Any other questions?
Balance?
General comments?
So I'll be here
afterwards if you guys
want to ask any questions.
If you want to look
through our old bot.
At some point I will
write out a code
walk through of our 2012 bot.
But until then
just ask, or we'll
be in the IRC
channel or whatever.
So hopefully this was
useful to you guys.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]